are you hiring you know where to post
your job to find out the best candidates
zip recruiter dot-com zip recruiter post
your job over 100 or the web's leading
job boards with just one click and then
zip recruiter actively looks for the
most qualified candidates and invites
them to apply that's why 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day Gareth I use Garrett Corey
uses that zip recruiters the smartest
way to hire finer today why super cooter
has been used by businesses of all sizes
and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now my listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right free just go to zip
recruiter calm slash dollop that zip
recruiter dot-com slashed up one more
time try for free go to zip recruiter
DICOM dollop you're listening to the
dollop this is by weekly American
history podcast each week once a week I
tea drinker lover of watches Wow smeller
of Grass Dave Anthony real story from
American history to his friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about why are you
touching it's the problem when you get
cameras involved now you're adding like
visual elements that Garrett just do
these naked and not tell anyone what
does it mean I'm trying to get naked
with you by any means all necessary is
jam-packed ok
hardcore fishing tomorrow now hit him
with the puppy you both present sick
arguments no I said my friend
we have some dates coming up Wow
live dollops yeah it's very we're
getting very professional in there we've
added a second show on staff just go on
the 2nd of February we have added a
second show in Seattle on the 22nd of
February a second show in Portland on
the 23rd of February in Kansas City no
in Indianapolis we have added a second
show on the 3rd of March and now we have
on sale minneapolis tickets on the 16th
of august I believe that sold out are
it's very close to sold out so we're
looking at a couple options to open
things up yeah might do it where the
Vikings play might do where the Vikings
play hair Dome hair dome there also be
at the improv on the 24th doing
unfortunately a comedy show with Karen
kill Gary unfortunately Dave the 24th
people aren't gonna be able to make that
because nobody going to my show at 10:00
p.m. at flappers where I'll be doing an
hour not sharing it with anyone so
that's I hate to do this I hate to do
this and so good the 27th of January
I'll be doing setlist somewhere don't do
this Valentine's Day come spend it with
me at flappers again won't you but this
is the hard sell
yeah and then there's other stuff ok I'm
pretty bad so we have t-shirts that are
for sale on a red bubble
most of our artists done by James Foster
Aikido stands for our Christopher horn
does a little bit those are both on red
bubble there's a company called T Spring
which is oddly has a lot of artists art
on their site and they're selling
t-shirts and they don't have the right
to do that and then you give them a
takedown notice and they take their time
will get and then 10 more pop up so
that's teespring
do not ever ever ever use teespring
that's art that's art we're starting a
campaign against teespring because
they're doing it as so many artists do
do it - Kamal Bell they're doing - don't
do will understand they're like it it's
just so many people are doing it - so
we're gonna start a little campaign
against teespring we should get shirts
made
well you get your tomato so if you want
our teachers go to red bubble go to the
James Foss Dyke page on there yeah we we
are also sponsored by talk space now
it's an online therapy company it lets
you message a licensed therapist from
anywhere at any time all you need is a
computer the internet connection and
then you know ASAP and something you
need to talk about right means you can
improve your mental health
sure so like an example it's like say
say you're a guy who sure I'll see where
this goes what do you mean well I mean
this is quite a leap from yeah but I'm
just I'm interested to see where you're
taking this um say you know you fired
one of your close friends sure
try think of all the stuff that happen
this week cuz there's so much [ __ ] well
I think the big one was well let's say
all right Dave
say you're a guy who in a meeting where
people who keep records are calls other
nations that aren't full of white people
[ __ ] holes oh and a lot of people think
hey that's super racist because you were
like no we should just have the Dutch
come in instead but Sam a guy who
doesn't care if you think I'm racist
well that's a guy that you're talking
about that's a guy toc-toc space.com
therapy is as easy as sending your
therapist a message get something off
your chest whatever you need to do I
talk about everyday challenges you've
gone to a lot of therapy you could
probably talk about it for hours but you
can just chat about lighting ready to do
it now if that's what you're asking
so now with talk space if you have to
leave your house you don't believe your
office you can just do it right there
and there's no judgments which you are
very judgmental remember I don't I don't
like problems
therapy isn't much as venting your
innermost thoughts or digging into your
childhood memories it's also about
practical everyday strategies for stress
management and living a happier life the
talks platform platform has over 2,000
licensed therapists who are experienced
in addressing life challenges we all
face to match with a perfect therapist
for a fraction of the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space.com
slash top and use the code dogs yet
thirty dollars off your first month and
show your support rocks face delecia
like like dating apps do like tinder
does when you Matt you can match with a
therapist and it's like
have a match you have a therapist Oh
boom yeah come on Aaron give me
something uh that's doll up and talk
space talk space.com slash dollop yeah
that I don't huh how my wife would feel
about that she's therapist we also uh we
use a square space as our as our site I
use it for my my personal website Dave
Anthony comm Sam here for our sources
use it for yours yes I do David yes I do
Gareth website right it's super easy
that's why your colleague three all
three years at Hughes Garrick or
obviously over there obviously it's a
super easy thing they got a bunch of
great templates it's super easy to work
with and right on and it's you know not
that expensive it's and I it's totally
affordable yeah so I guess a beautiful
templates they have e-commerce
functionality so if you want you can do
that on there
look feels it's great everything's
optimized you know you are suggesting
that that Squarespace feels right I'm
saying it feels like super hot okay it's
free and secure hosting nothing to patch
up great ever 24/7 customer support
so with Squarespace oh look we got a
whole thing here think it dream it make
it with Squarespace wait a minute hold
on wait let's let staff Punk that you
know destiny is calling it says you need
to need a new website make it with
Squarespace the future is coming make it
brighter no I like the one that sounded
like Daft Punk did it I think it feel it
make it do it have it go for it put it
upload hour after hour Squarespace work
is never over alright so head to head to
squarespace.com for free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code all to say 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain that
squarespace.com and her code dollop
that's the name of our do ll oh now
Gareth and I got a new sponsor it's fit
fit fabfitfun and what it is is they
they sent us the thing and they're like
so it's a box of uh
make up and like it's all kinds of stuff
it seemed very geared towards ladies and
and I was like I has like gee why do you
guys want us to try this stuff
oh well it's kind of like a tail part
where it's just like it's sitting in the
room and you're just like I don't need
this stuff and then eventually you've
got a little poncho on and you're
putting on eyeliner just like look I'm a
lady and I do what I like so what
happened in my house is they say this is
a sample box so what it is is it's a
it's a company they put together a bunch
of like cool stuff in a box and then you
get it sent to you it's like fun sized
products of makeup and other stuff it's
also real products it's not muscle soak
there's a muscle don't ask it's great
value they don't repeat products not
like a bandit mask like clay masks of
somewhere like a you know exfoliator and
get out of here and they do like
seasonal stuff so you get this stuff and
I was like what am I gonna do with it
and then my wife goes is this for me
yeah and I was like yes it's for you
yeah and I'm expecting her to open up
and be like and she's [ __ ] squealing
and like oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay
I'm not gonna these are all my colors
they're gonna even know what you're
talking about right now you have colors
and then she puts on this poncho thing
and she's like I've always wanted one
she's like my trend hasn't me I guess I
did good here no my mother ravaged mine
like a raccoon was like like take out
just thrown straight in the garbage she
was like oh yeah yeah she went apeshit
over the poncho yes anyway so yeah the
poncho so so you get it comes four times
a year it's 499 4999 a box it's like I
said what I what I witnessed my wife
went crazy for it so I recommend it
quite a bit
so we just got our fun fit fabfitfun box
it's hard at for me to say yeah
obviously my wife loved it so if you
want to get this go use our code to get
10/10 doze off your first box try
fabfitfun today go to fabfitfun calm to
subscribe and start getting the box for
a life well-lived
sure use promo code dollop to get $10
off your first box its products valued
at $200 for only $39.99
which seems like a deal again go to fab
fit fun calm and use code dog to get $10
off your first box boom there's a lot of
squealing in my house when that when I
was coming my stuff was the rats there
are a lot of rats
was it the rats again Dave we have a lot
of rats in our house I'm what I'm
suggesting is you get a rat terrier so
we ship rat terriers got a rat terrier
calm no not a lot of podcasts are giving
you beasts to fight off household vermin
but the dollop is blazing a trail so uh
anything else don't have anything else
to tell people I think we've said enough
we have a book for sale whatever you
guys can find a lot of stuff yeah keep
those book checks cuz February 11th 1907
okay William Levitt was born in Brooklyn
New York his father was Abraham Levitt
he was from England Abraham originally
but raised over here in the US he was a
real estate investor and he dabbled a
bit oh he's real estate lawyer dabbled a
bit in and he represented houses he
represented houses like sir your honor
my clients a two-story home okay I rest
my job well there's no there's no
actually case against your house I know
that's part of the big problem here how
are you getting paid well the house I
don't know actually
okay so you're bad at all this yeah
guilty guilty
William had one younger brother Alfred
he was like five years younger William
attended school in New York and then
went on to go to New York University in
1929 his father Abraham started a real
estate development sure company
he called it Levitt & Sons catchy so it
also makes you think that maybe the sons
are about love it or love it
why don't you go with that that's
already way better the thing wasn't then
obviously if sons are supposed to be
involved in the business the Great
Depression forced a proper so they're
doing this deal to develop property and
then the Great Depression hits which I
guess a lot of people was a bummer
do you think by putting great on it
we've sort of sullied how shitty it
really was cuz to me that's just weird
make rate on something that's that Jerry
should be called the the [ __ ]
shittiest approach it II depression
should worse depression worse the brand
if you tell people were headed for
another worse depression I think people
maybe let you know yeah this the small
sect of the population might be like oh
that's bad I think they weren't really
thinking about names but the fantastic
depression so it forced this property
developer they were working with to
default on payments and then Abraham
livet had to step in and complete the
job himself to protect his investment
okay so he has no experience with the
construction so he calls on his sons who
were in college to help both dropped out
of college joined up and went to work
okay the upscale development was called
Strathmore you had a policy to not to
sell to Jews okay so okay good you know
sometimes it's the podcast is a little
bit like finding truffles uh-huh yeah
you know sometimes you got to dig for a
little while other times they're just
sitting right in front has that come
right out yes yes on you so so they so
their policy was to not rent to Jews
right here's um and we're we're in
America there's the there's the boys in
there dad we are weird in the New York
area okay so the one on the right there
with the woman the glasses definitely
looks like he's got a no jew policy
that's Alfred that's Alfred yeah okay
they're Jewish did I not mention that I
think they're Jews who decided for
business reasons to not you guys get it
right the anti-semitic Jew I thought was
just a stand-up comic not even a somatic
now to them it's just strictly a
business decision that's the other Jews
are probably
ya know that's what I was gonna say yeah
it's sort of like this weird like money
that's a it's a semitic where jews okay
i'm and it worked
okay Strathmore was such a success that
levin and sons purchased more long
island farmland and built more homes
throughout the depression okay so and
and it was good for farmers to at the
time because of the golden nematode
which you oh the golden nematode the
golden worm also yeah yellow potato well
those that let me let me go ahead but uh
well you finish your thought and then
I'll jump in as far as my thought on all
those things well it's ravaging the
potato crops obviously obviously and so
farmers are just looking to sell yeah
and exactly when that was a big part of
worm and that was a big part of it was
the gold Neil work yeah so wait what's
going on so it's basically a perfect
time to buy land and but because farmers
crops are just getting eaten i to
getting wasted by this [ __ ] golden
eel golden you can call it the golden
nematode or one of these is a lond movie
is this where I'm supposed to pick which
ones about a movie yeah I think the
golden eels the ball yeah I do it where
me so the so they have this like I said
no no Jewish policy doesn't affect them
at all they sell like crazy it's it's a
great deal
okay and then they're buying up this
land that used to be farmland do you
build a potato land as the Levites built
they got better and better at it more
and more efficient they built mostly
upscale houses around Long Island and
then 1930s William became the company
president while his younger brother
Alfred designed the homes okay all right
sure
that you see the guys there yeah dad's
my dad a constant this constant
happiness there's William did I give you
away I'm over there yeah there's William
yeah William frenum was one of his maps
I love maps you see right there he's
working yeah clearly
that doesn't look staged at all William
swims President Alfred's the like
designer then World War two came and
Leben sons want a Navy contract to build
cheap homes for shipyard workers in
Virginia okay they figured out the non
art of mass production techniques okay
the war also led William to enlist in
the Navy in 1943 so William goes to war
that one is William yeah okay that Gary
he's the main guy right sorry is that
right yeah in 1944 the GI Bill of Rights
was passed it was designed to reabsorb
millions of returning vets at a time
when housing is in short supply so all
these guys coming back from war right
you got not enough houses for people
right it's a total [ __ ] show the bill
gave veterans in small small business
loans right so you're a vet you get a
small business loan you can get college
tuition job training hiring privileges
unemployment payments and low-interest
mortgages okay so housing construction
goes bananas sure right totally through
the roof from a hundred and fourteen
thousand new homes in 1944 to 1.7
million new homes in 1950 that's a
pretty big increase yeah okay if I'm
doing math it's like eight percent yeah
something close to that this is
obviously very exciting unless you're a
black guy right because of the GI is
first 67,000 mortgages fewer than 100
were taken up by non-whites and that's
not because they didn't want them right
it's because they just weren't being
offered and now we just want to see how
this goes oh did we not oh we should
have called it the white GI Bill but
basically all these guys went and fought
for our country black guys coming back
thinking well we fought for the country
so now we get to be a part of the dream
and then they were just a door slammed
in their face right and then they're
just there's a hundred that they get so
they have lottery odds of getting a home
that's bad
so when William came back he had picked
up in his time in the Navy cheaper and
faster ways to build okay so they must
have put him to work
if you hold a gun at an employee said he
moved they really work hard guys so so
they're building he realized they can
crank it out fast if they do it the way
that he learned so there's there's
thousands of new married couples looking
for an affordable place to live okay
William realized if they built a ton of
identical homes all with the newest
appliances they could sell them cheap it
was to be the first planned community in
America it's the first suburb right Wow
only
they call that Levittown did they do
what it's fine
they call that Levittown New York they
used Henry Ford's Detroit assembly line
I wrote yeah man yeah teams of workers
put up identical houses like they were
working in a factory they were able to
build 36 houses a day
there's no basements no garages and
nothing to tell the houses apart they
use pre-cut lumber and they were built
on concrete slabs okay
they had to have the building codes
changed because most places didn't allow
you to build on concrete slabs but then
there was such a need for houses yeah go
ahead go ahead do it on the slab they
wouldn't allow you to build on concrete
slabs no I think it's makes for less
stable house a slab does yeah okay I
think of it I think if no I have
absolutely no idea but I think if you
build it on the ground and you put you
know you put beams into the ground or
whatever you do you're gonna have more
flexible sort of situation but if you
just build on a slab you talking about
cracking you're talking about right you
know okay I gave it just and then it
doesn't give as much what the land is it
settles or whatever I would imagine
that's it I call my brother after this I
could totally be totally wrong yeah call
your brother yeah now okay I'm trying to
find this construction picture which I
can't the one that isn't the one that
says construction know sometimes it's
this one okay so that's what they look
like so there's guys putting together a
house so they literally are putting
together about to do a musical wait guys
so while they're building the house they
put down this lab and then they've got
wood around it and then they've got
they've got kitchen [ __ ] they've got
they find the white picket fence is
sitting right there ready to get put up
refrigerator stove like it's all there
like they just bring it in all at once
right it's not a [ __ ] day yeah it's
very sick like when I first moved to LA
like the easiest place to rent was just
this place that was like you know that
exact same they all the same the walls
are thin as [ __ ] they give you
everything yeah that'll be easy
yeah so uh so they basically cut out the
middleman they're using non-union
which brought picket lines and then
they're buying directly from
manufacturers divided everything right
you know TV free whatever it's in there
right people wanted them first they
rented then they sold the price was for
a house six thousand nine hundred ninety
dollars probably furnished home me all
the buyer need it was a ninety dollar
deposit oh my god I'll take thirty fifty
eight dollars some oh my god Wow
most Leviton homes were bought by return
honey it's pretty steep it's ninety
dollars how we gonna afford this honey
come on I just feel like in two years
we're gonna be kicking ourselves so it's
mostly done by mostly bought by young G
eyes coming back sure not black ones
no the the morning the first homes went
up for rent one thousand five hundred
families lined up outside the place look
at this so there's a big line of people
waiting to buy the places they're all
those people lined up waiting to buy a
house that's on the first time here well
they're renting to own that's basically
what it is if a patient some camped
overnight and they worried the houses
would be gone in the morning there's
like fifteen hundred houses if they line
up for him right Levittown was on top of
every little detail residents who were
sometimes called Levitt owners of God
we're at first expected to comply with a
lengthy list of rules about the upkeep
of their homes and how they use their
property interesting one rule was that
they couldn't hang laundry out to dry on
Sunday oh well that one makes it stink
yeah right I mean if it's related to God
it has to be why else do you can't see
someone get away with these God
connection hold on but you you hold on
you can't it's totally reasonable on the
on the day of the day the week of our
Lord we celebrate him that you don't see
where a piece of clothing where you keep
your junk so we talked to God again
today he's not happening he again has
another bizarre request we understand
he's made some very strange ones like
wine is his blood and crackers his body
yes sir are you guys to eat and drink
him he now is against when you guys
put your clothes out on Sunday coz that
because well it's his day uh-huh and he
just doesn't like any of that stuff he
doesn't like chores on his day but
especially not you know especially not
getting clothes okay so I think if
you're him yep clothes on a line on a
Sunday it doesn't mean anything
Wow um I think to most people it's
pretty clear that would be CNN back in
that time you know you should be able to
hang up your clothes on Sunday I think
that Jesus is upset by it well we've
heard uh interesting debates from both
sides I guess we'll never know if Jesus
wants your clothes up or not they're
also not a lot of Defense in their yards
there's a fence out there uh well at
first they what do you mean there was a
fence on that other picture you put up
oh well that's it first been taken later
but they couldn't fence in the yards at
first if you didn't take care of your
lawn you'd get a bill they said where
every tree could be planted and how
every bush should be trimmed so it's
hardline conformity which also included
people william promised homeowners a
quote escape from the claustrophobia of
city life okay k a black people here we
go so the man is now creating the first
suburb and he's already segregating oh
yeah it's a suburb come on there'll be
so few black people you won't need
fences come on down to the Levittown
Levittown errs what racist
so Levitt said he wasn't a racist i but
he's making a business decision you
can't making a business if you're
allowed good god and he wasn't concerned
with making the world a better place
just making money he said that like he's
not he's like I'm not about making the
world better I'm about making money a
quote if we sell one house to a Negro
family ninety to ninety-five percent of
our white customers would not buy into
the community its business son it's so
weird that it how is it we live in
time where that sounds familiar like two
hours yeah I mean you know because
everything's great
this also helped I'm not racist but
never never cuz right he also said this
would help the homeowners retain the
value of their property sure because you
know black people live in a house then
it's a it's a right worse sure he's
saying no cool a few black families
could take down the whole development oh
my god take like if properly placed if
properly placed every nine houses you
put a black family well then the whole
thing's a wash we've got to be very very
careful here and buy wash we don't mean
what we're doing on Sundays praise Jesus
Wayne explain they couldn't both tackle
segregation and the housing crisis at
the same time how could we do that wait
you mean it's actually the best time to
tackle it wait a minute I know it's like
when he's saying like look I'm a
businessman it's like yeah but you also
with this move yeah simply could make it
better but instead no no no no we'll go
with what people think
Jordan literally reconstructing how
America is built this would be exactly
the time talking about a city on a hill
no black people all right guys let's get
in these houses it's like this is when
you integrate yeah but he was hopeful
that someday as far as like white people
goes this would be like sneaking
vegetables into the cookies you could
easily right now just sort of be like
and this is what's normal now and people
be like Oh houses okay yeah
so he's he's hopeful that someday it'll
be different quote as a Jew I have no
room in my heart for racial prejudice
but the plain fact is that most whites
prefer not to live in mixed communities
this man attitude may be morally wrong
and it some day may change I hope it
will yeah he's walking he's on the
razor's edge so stuff like that's like
that's like the standard sort of right
family and house white white people
small house you know family of three or
family of four or five two point five
two point five yeah at the time it was
legal to not sell or read to minorities
of course the Federal Housing
Administration actually offered
mortgages to non-mixed developments
which encourage developers to create
white almond communities Wow language
was what is their plan know what the
[ __ ] plan his language was put into
the housing contracts that the homes
could not be quote be used or occupied
by any person other than members of the
Caucasian race so that's in the contract
to buy the house in the contract which
is normal what year are we in now this
is uh like the late 40s mid minish
forties but someone did sue over white
only developments Wow it went to the
Supreme Court okay surprisingly well let
me wait let me guess
they sought justice I mean they actually
did they shockingly they disagreed
ruling such restrictions were to be
unenforceable as law and contrary to
public policy so they say you can't do
that no you can't just you can't have a
Caucasian contract William Levitt had
the language remove from the contracts
but the white only policy continued oh
that's fine we'll take it out we'll just
keep doing it thank you
instead they used dog whistles in the
Leviton message it was called quote a
private haven in a heartless world a
white picket fence a place where parents
wouldn't have to worry about the worry
there's bolded there's a lot of winking
yeah yeah well that's when we came up
with our spokesperson white wink Minh
yes he's always tipping his hat to
something it's never dark out at
Levittown white Wakeman you won't need
to lock your doors when it's dark white
Wickman ding um so you know the houses
are you've seen it you've seen these
kind of places they just all look the
[ __ ] same yeah I mean that's all
America is now really no and it's weird
because while yeah like this it feels
like it's really become that in like the
last like 10 years yeah yeah the weird
thing is to look at it from above
oh jesus well that is like the thing
that's so crazy when you fly when you
fly in general but when you fly into LA
yeah
so that's as I said the house is sold
fast 1,400 families moved into the
all-white Levittown within the first
three hours of the office opening its
doors they were renting with an option
to buy the company kept building and
soon had made over 17,000 homes and if
you're making 36 homes a day that's not
hard if you have the [ __ ] land it's
still crazy
Leviton was so successful it's like fits
like it looks like factory farming yeah
you know yeah it really does
Levittown was so successful that William
Levitt was put on the cover of Time
magazine in July 1950 anti-semitic Jew
races no it's just like Jew finds out
how to move white people out of the city
Jew sticks to racist values blames
business and bad Jews they want to build
other Levittown's in Pennsylvania New
Jersey Puerto Rico and Maryland the park
just is so weird to me but yeah I guess
well I mean a Puerto Rico actually has a
pretty large Caucasian population yeah
Levittown so they had not enough in this
day and age to help yeah sorry we cut
you guys lose something if you know that
so Levittown has a public elementary
schools Olympic size pools there's parks
there's baseball fields just playgrounds
a shopping it's a suburb they built a
suburb right I built a place you never
have to leave that's exactly right
this is white flight this is people
running from the cities right by the
time the last Levitt and Sons house was
purchased in 1951 they had earned the
distinction of having completed the
largest housing development ever
constructed by a single builder as they
built more and more they started
building what they called ranches which
had a carport and a TV built into the
staircase wait so there yeah so you know
the staircase goes up underneath
you know where you would in a horror
movie you would lock up a child okay you
can wear Harry Potter you have a caged
human in a horror movie that's the best
way I can describe does it come with a
caged child let's talk about how does
how does the staircase it works can you
take the TV out and there's a hole and
you put the bars in and that's where you
keep the people you captured oh we don't
need the TV plugged in it's just a dupe
I'm there before I change what we don't
need is black people it's just where
Harry Potter goes Dave
[Applause]
so a magazine was made you know where
you torture people in your house if you
can sew a magazine is created what I
don't I didn't write down the name I
don't know why somebody usually do but
it was just simply it was just a
magazine for how to expand and remodel
and decorate Levitt homes okay so
there's so many [ __ ] homes and so
many people trying to probably make them
slightly different than their neighbors
right they're actually putting on a
magazine telling people that's that's
also kind of genius in a way too though
to sell everything the exact same and
then be like want to make yours stand
out yeah it's totally it's like [ __ ]
IKEA yeah really there are a PA if you
go on a website there are IKEA mods a
website the internet if you put in IKEA
mods there's all these people doing
stuff to make your IKEA thing look
different how long until IKEA just makes
a home kit no no we're all gonna die
eventually mobility able to break your
home down like a Lego hut probably gonna
be pretty advantageous and move it yeah
well we're floating all right beggars
feel like we practice well yeah even
think of like what happened in Hawaii
yesterday when they were told there was
an imminent missile headed towards them
like you get in a little IKEA pack home
alright guys collapse the home get your
backpacks
I would I would take 38 minutes to send
out the reverse message saying there
weren't and you would take 38 minutes
unless you know you're trying to sell
ballistic missile defense system there
right
apparently it was a very exciting
tourist destination as well and was a
what that was a white wingman if I've
ever seen the July 1950 issue of the
NASA daily review Star reported that
Levittown's frame has spread so widely
fame sorry quote Levittown's fame has
spread so widely both in America and
abroad that it now ranks near the Statue
of Liberty among the seven wonders which
New York City visitors want to see so
the suburb over the Statue of Liberty so
people dude so with a check in the mail
with the chick was in the mail for our
demise for ages we'll just fell behind
the couch or something people would come
in there extending back man this is
beautiful I saw that that big building
you got I saw the statue lady what about
all these homes that look the same
where's that cul-de-sac at work can I
just see the street you drive down and
everything looks exactly the same
including the people do you have that
because I want to feel like I'm in some
sort of crazy twilight zone in the movie
business I believe they call it the
b-roll city is that around here Wayne
Levitt was now one of the richest people
in the world
well good people get rewards William had
a huge ego what from what he lived
lavishly if you can imagine he was that
a selfie that is him out on his boat is
that the picture of him er is that his
boat in the background that's him on a
boat that might be his boat in the
background as well he might have a big
yacht oh he might share made it a
foreground shot but it's him and his
lady this was a story about how awesome
their lives were he bragged he hated all
exercise except for golf and would only
read newspapers and magazines no books
only he leased a huge apartment on Fifth
Avenue in Manhattan he had a limo and a
driver when he went to eat with a group
he would tell everyone where to sit and
then order their food for them he always
had a steak my god what
uh well it's Bobby you sit there you're
having you're having soup and bread just
plain bread okay I'm really nice you're
having a salad and yeah just a salad you
sit on the floor no I don't tell him
yeah Brett can I get maybe something to
eat I didn't eat all day cuz I thought
maybe I could get some food tonight
entitlement I'm gonna have a steak nice
juicy medium-rare now let's go medium
okay so one salad a soup two breads and
a medium-rare steak for a Garcon
yeah can you make all of them sit on the
floor absolutely get others chairs
[ __ ] get out of those chairs will
you money on the ground also every time
you bring my steak could you put it down
and wink at me and say man you are rich
absolutely
Thank You Manuel rich thank you here's a
tip $0.50 my other tip is buy Levittown
house my other tip is keep out everyone
who's not pure white in July 1957 B and
Lou Wechsler a Jewish couple who lived
in Levittown so they sell the Jewish
people they snuck in they decided to
sell their home okay
now oh they're not gonna do something
crazy like B and Lou were white radicals
who were friendly with a lot of
Communists okay they believed the whites
only Levittown policy was not cool and
that racial equality was a necessary
part of American how did they sneak into
Levittown with these open-minded values
I think that some people they have to
dig a hole to get under the fence I bet
some people moved there and then we're
kind of shocked at what how because this
is much less segregated than a lot of
other places like this is like the
extreme example but I bet they were or
they lived there for a little while and
got radicalized or their plan was to buy
and do this it'd be great to go there
and there's the first thing you do is
convert to Judaism right away so what
did they do well William Myers was born
in New York and raised in Pennsylvania
Myers enlisted during the war and he
served two and a half years fighting for
his country when he came home he used
the GI Bill to go to college after he
met
married Daisy and they started a family
okay few years later he was working as
an engineer in a refrigeration test
laboratory yeah this was called in New
Jersey this is also called Daisy this
isn't as cold this I don't know if you
know what engineered super called again
I think colder than the first two I
think what you're talking about is maybe
a guy that you would I'm picturing a guy
working in a fridge Factory yeah I'm no
but you're you literally not even a
fridge fire because it's got a fridge
tract with make fridges you literally
know your mind
that's the tired of guy who tests
whether it's cold yeah they're on the
test floor so he just walks in opposed
to having a temperature gauge no dude
he's opening a bunch of different like
cold things yep
oh this is very cold yeah
so I we're learning why you should never
have a company your core is thriving do
we not have a gear core cold tester
okay I'm Hamlet oh this is freezing this
is very cold this so Daisy has a degree
in education she's a she's a he's
educated she's educated he offers
countries they're sort of the good
people well they're the typical sort of
American couple at this age sure happen
to be black sure oh okay right so the
bachelors sold their house to the Meijer
okay they're not radicals they're not
political they're just a black family
who want a nice life they had two kids
RJ pregnant with the third are they
aware of the no okay bill had seen the
news about the promise of life in
Levittown America's first suburb it
meant having a community and a sense of
security and for the Myers have been
moving into a new America right the
house was three bedrooms and had a
two-car garage there's a corner lot for
the first two days Bill and Daisy came
and cleaned up the house okay so what
does that look like if you're a white
guy who's lives next door but black
people come in and clean up the house
what's that look like oh no oh no oh God
right they think they're cleaners oh my
god just like on the third day maybe you
guys do all the houses around here
right the honey they're funny they said
they're moving here on the third day
August 13th they moved in they way these
cleaners seem to be furnishers - these
are very bold cleaners I like these are
our Rangers and cleaners they were the
first black family to move in since
Levittown and open ten years before when
the mailman came I should say this is
the Pennsylvania Levittown right now
baby not the original okay so this is
the Pennsylvania Levittown which was
built around the same time okay so the
mailman comes and he knocks on the door
and Daisy answers and he asked to speak
to the owner hi miss what are you he
thought she was the maid oh my god Daisy
said I am the owner and the mammon said
quote you you're the owner that's right
he handed her a letter and walked off
like he'd been punched in the face oh my
god Daisy said to Bill quote he looked
ill the mailman then went door to door
speaking like a racist Paul Revere quote
it happened [ __ ] have moved to
Levittown he went and said that at every
house that he went to it really is like
so yeah that's just [ __ ] crazy within
15 minutes of the mammon coming to the
house small groups of people started
gathering on the lawn of the house
across the street so now people are just
showing up because black people have
moved in there just so irate they're now
just like gasp trying to be like you
can't live here I think it's part I
really know are they more fascinated I
think that they're yeah I think that
they're like well I'm sure some are
irate but I think a lot are just like
what what could possibly be did you hear
okay that's crowd start together Wow
that's how you that's how you make
that's how you make people feel
comfortable yet so then she's right
outside because we're black hun they're
just in little groups yeah and they're
kind of you know in different areas
watching this corner little corner
imagine dude it's whoa so then the phone
rang and Daisy answered it and it was a
hysterical woman screaming I don't want
to freak you out but black people have
moved into the neighborhood
Oh God quote I will not let my children
King chocolate milk again as long as I
live then she hung up
okay so no just okay now let's say that
to your core no Dave let's say to your
core you feel because of the race of
someone you you can't have your kids do
something yeah I think with a little
more thought you could come up with
something better than what what I would
say was a open-air absolvo a terrible
terrible clearly racist but not creative
jab I won't up my kids drink chocolate
milk I mean it's like she didn't want to
be super wisest but she wanted to be
racist right like she's maybe a
church-going lady and that's the best
she can come I'd love to see the list of
the other three she had on there before
she went with that daisy ass bill if
they if he thought there would be any
trouble and he assured her there was
nothing to worry about
the Wechsler is phone rang shortly after
where they know now they've moved
somewhere else they live nearby there it
was one of their old neighbors if they
did they know that it'll be see this so
they're doing this is of the radical
move to like sort of yeah they've gone
up tin it so there's this we're
disconnecting where they've gone as far
as to contact certain people to tell
them this is happening and they've
contacted and a lawyer has sent a letter
to the Leviton offices in the police
department right like a people in
authority positions have been warned by
the Wechsler x' and others the people
who don't seem to know are the Myers
right people moving in right so there's
that's food there's a thing happening
there that's oh you're on a reality show
so
the West Was phone rings it's one of
their old neighbors he just screams you
nigger-loving Jewish [ __ ] this
would be the first of one of many calls
to Wechsler house so people who live
there makes you miss the chocolate
market all livid that this Jewish
couples we're [ __ ] radical soul2soul
to a black like they the betrayal right
we let you Jews move in and we bit our
tongues but then you Jew sold the blacks
not in Levittown baby in the afternoon
the Leviton Times newspaper came out on
page 2 near the bottom was ash oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
that's what's written in it by Jane
Sussman oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god okay oh my god okay okay remember
the West oh my god oh my god
quote the first Negro family to buy a
Leviton home and then it briefly
describes them reports they moved in 243
deep green lane in the dogwood hollow
section that morning it said the family
was made up of William Myers his wife
Daisy and their three small children
although it's not three small it's two
and she's pregnant well it's still small
inside car start driving by so what so
then when she reads in the Levittown
paper that they're featured is the first
no she hasn't read it because she's not
getting the paper yet they just moved in
right okay they have no idea car start
driving by homeboy to two hours
there's so many cars that there's now a
traffic jam in front of the house quite
a few cars start displaying Confederate
flags oh boy because it's Pennsylvania
the side that fought against by 7:30
p.m. reporters started showing up they
took pictures and interviewed people who
are now milling about what do you think
about this black thing well everybody's
still totally freaked out here on the
ground Diane back to you guys I mean
I'll put up a YouTube there's a docking
like it's it's not a documentary it's
just a guy sort of exploring the
mindsets he's just asking people
questions and you just can't believe
like there's a normal person
who's like yeah it's fine you know they
moved here and then there's a guy that's
like I have four children what are they
gonna do what's happening right now in a
shot around this time exact same exact
time it's an amazing i watch the whole
thing I was just like staring at these
people so then a drunk man comes to the
door this is the first night comes to
their house demands to know who had sold
them the house quote how much did you
pay for it what right do you have to
come I just want to find the people who
sold it just tell me what their names
are bill tells him to chuck the check
the public record which the drunk guy
then shouted to the crowd that they
should check the public record and
someone yelled quote something is gonna
happen I'm sticking around to see so
that guy's just excited about the
potential coming violence yeah there's
that guy who's like man there's gotta be
some good right now come on yeah he
hears the public record news he's like
oh come on that's gonna take a long time
and we're drunk so the Myers are
definitely thinking this was now going
to be a problem sure the crowd is now
big and very angry now that's just a
photo of the people I think after
they've been moved across the street but
they're on their lawn they're they're
not staying in an area they are
everywhere surrounding [ __ ]
alien-like oh [ __ ] yeah can you even
imagine I mean I can't even imagine what
do you see what so it's literally if you
if this picture that I put up it's it's
it's a street and then across the street
there are just a hundred white bean oh
yeah looking people waiting for like the
Beatles like to come out yeah so women
were swearing and spitting men were
angrily grumbling many said they had
come here because William Levitt
promoted it as a whites-only community
some shouted quote live it promised
like little babies far away what judges
what are you someone shouted quote no
one wants them here let's drive them out
the Meijer next-door neighbors who were
totally 100% fine with them living there
they came out and tried to calm down the
crowd the neighbor told them that the
Meijer had the same right to buy a house
as anyone else here does and then an
angry man stepped up and got in his face
you should be ashamed of yourself our
houses are worth only half of what they
were yesterday oh my god now apparently
I didn't apparently there was an
appraisal who appraised this the Klan
well this house looks all good now who's
living next door
soon the neighbor realized that his
safety was at stake and a friend of his
actually said you got to get out of here
okay so he retreats back to us right so
even defending this situation is yeah
your life's in danger
so bill and Daisy called the cops and
plead for help their kids are now
bawling they felt I mean that
conversation could very easily have just
been one where they're just like yes
we're calling about the Myers who have
moved into a Levittown like a man we are
aware of that and we're doing everything
we can to get him out of the house no
we're the Meijer oh hi
number call back sit tight new phone who
this you're going to be fine
so they they from the conversation they
felt like the cops had no intention of
coming
then they heard two men yelling outside
they should get dynamite and blow up the
house yeah that's gonna bring your
property values back up yeah now they've
been cut in half
I think the appraisal is really gonna
enjoy the fact that some of them explode
look bombings are good for yeah that's
that's that helps every that helps the
local economy at minimum yeah so then
the cops actually did come and the Myers
were obviously relieved but it didn't
last long as they watched out their
window the cops did nothing to disperse
the crowd instead they just started
ticketing cars that were parked
turns out a lot of the cops lived in
Levittown so the Myers has had it this
is I mean this is like a horror film if
you're let me yes oh thank god the cops
are here well Matt Matt Damon apparently
that he did a movie this year there was
about this but downsizing but they
didn't make a lot of the connections
that you're saying I think it was based
on this and then there's that right yeah
I think what they want to do is do a
movie about this and then as they got
through the production process it became
about nothing so I haven't seen it
so the Myers have had had enough they
ran to their car as they held their kids
the reporters took photos the crowd
jeered at them the crowd slowly parted
as they drove through and after they
were gone leaders started to emerge from
the group stood and gave speeches as the
others listened the crowd was now about
250 people
so those speeches are just like you see
if we stand together we could keep this
a white like that sort of yeah I mean
look one guy I read about he's from
North Carolina and you know why he moved
here was so it would be a white only
place like there's a there's a lot of
there's a lot of southern influence that
you know I felt when I was reading about
this so a group of teenagers then threw
rocks through the front picture window
at that point six cop cars pulled up and
15 policemen came onto the lawn carrying
clubs and the sheriff arrived the crowd
started to get more and more out of hand
I don't know if I have a picture of the
window do I large crowd no looks like I
didn't bring it it was too small
it's weird thing about when you're going
on google photos to find photos some of
the pictures are tiny you're like white
I know like when you drag one you're
just like yeah no this is for a mouse's
wallet so a a 45 year old man and his
wife got arrested while they were being
put in the car a woman yelled quote come
on
let's everybody get arrested let's make
a big thing out of this what is like
mobs just can't hang out for too long
it's just ridiculous otherwise its
loudest idea wins
that's three teenagers we threw the
rocks arrested somewhere people then
came to the conclusion they should call
and get William Levitt to save them
right so they're like okay about our
hero our Lord and Savior
but when they called they were told
William Levitt had left town what
William had been warned Andy's been
doing laundry on Sunday what so he he
had been warned of the sale and he'd
just flown the coop okay
with all the reporters and photographers
he wanted to be nowhere near the mess
sure sure
the next morning the Myers family slowly
drove back to their house it was very
quiet they hadn't slept much the night
before trash and cigarette butts were
all over their lawn the front window had
holes in it but they were determined to
stay they made breakfast sure and then
the phone started ringing so they're
having a little breakfast comfortable
what now what do you talk about it at
breakfast after my birthday's sports so
how was your night Jimmy well I cried
all night because white people were
saying they wanted to blow the house all
right eat your toast any on white toast
this normal I mean think about what your
point people are out of their goddamn
minds here's the other things like ask
someone who has a kid and knowing what
my kid gets scared of yeah like this is
an unbelievable thing to explain to a
child oh yeah yeah oh my god so you
gotta make up something I think this
might be Santa Terry you can't make it
up because there are crazy [ __ ] white
[ __ ] on the lawn yelling [ __ ] like
there's no making anything up the kids
there should be a kid book called scuse
yd be a whole series excuse whitey
series why does he do it well it's just
one of those situations for right now
somewhere you gotta say excuse why he a
white Wakeman book so they go back to
their house they start they're having
breakfast then the phone starts ringing
this time it was family of friends who
had heard about what had happened on the
news and then even stranger started a
call from around the country one woman
called to say she was ashamed I'm
drinking chocolate milk again I
overreacted and I and my children will
now have chocolate milk again plus Jimmy
won't drink regular milk I only drink
chocolate
that was part of it but then I've been
thinking about it I decided that we will
all drink I was like should I'm not
chocolate I not eat chocolate and
there's so many there's so many Brown
things you know yeah so you know anyway
but it's a big step for me
I think this has been a good call and
I'll be drinking whiskey again and not
just gin as I was for a while I and the
clue is out and I'm not even sure who
that is that feels like it's white
Russian oh sorry there's no answering
machine what I'm doing why am i and this
isn't even a phone it's a bucket box of
tissues I'm holding no my ears are
bleeding oh I just realized I took acid
okay so one woman called to say she was
watching the news and she felt ashamed
to be white representative from the
Friends Service Association
I'm from friend services 50 [ __ ] is
happening now hey hey Bobby what do you
say we started what a friends
association like a friend service
association will just be friends with
people that's order that's what you just
got a knock at your door like how you
doing sir your name is Dan yeah and
you're friends with Travis yeah well
Travis didn't wanna bring this up but uh
earlier today you guys went to see a
movie and grabbed a bite to eat after
and um yeah well you said you'd pay him
back yeah for him picking up the tab and
you never did oh okay oh we're with
friend services by the way I'm sorry oh
I'm Sergeant Aaron I called you I called
you with the thank you right yeah
exactly yeah that was a fun case yeah
unfortunately you're on the other end of
this one so you could apologize to
Travis absolutely I love you guys yeah
yeah he just doesn't want to do it
alright we got a lot of sorry no I love
you guys all right yeah so we got a long
night ahead of us so we're gonna I don't
know what this community would be like
without the friend services Association
yeah we're here that's our slogan so
that's right my man right so the friend
service Association said they would help
throughout the day they got a chance I
try to figure out that meant I couldn't
figure out oh well help reporters came
and asked the Myers if they were going
to stay during the afternoon the kids
went next door to play with there's all
this horrible racism made it impossible
for you to live here it's so the kids go
next door to play with the neighborhood
kid then the neighbor kids next door who
are a friendly family sure but when they
were in the in the yard
suddenly pears started flying across the
street the big bully kid who lived there
was doing his thing so now it's just
just on pears they kept describing him
as this fat bully kid sure but he's just
like winging pears
ok ok the Myers hustled their kids
inside and then the mob began to grow
again now they were defying police
orders not to gather there were teenage
boys in blue jeans with greased hair
teenage girls and plaid sleeveless
shirts pregnant women carrying babies
and lots of men with their arms crossed
so everyone's just everything from the
outsiders to the sock hop gang it's so
it looks it's just a weird [ __ ]
situation Jesus it is very weird right
you got the babies you got the strollers
cars are the Confederate flag start
showing up again it's always a really
good so there's a combination of people
that live in the neighborhood and then
outside what I believe we now call
agitators there's like racists coming in
sure from other places to like you know
right hotspot yeah by 3:00 doke the
phone by 3:30 p.m. more than a thousand
cars had rolled by the crowd just keeps
getting bigger the cops tried but
couldn't keep them out at a p.m. the
Myers decided to leave again this time
the police X Corps escorted them out and
the crowd was quiet as they were marched
their car so baby yeah right baby Center
so you have a slight uptick in tolerance
human behavior by the right price
what's the Myers drove away the crowd
came back to life one man yelled quote
this is why I moved out of Philadelphia
it's nice that a guy just screamed I I
am part taking in white flight yeah
that's not what this is not at all what
was expected yeah yeah
police people started saying this was a
set up by the NAACP one woman said quote
whoever persuaded them to move here
naturally picked a model Negro family
it's the families that follow that worry
me oh that's nice
sweet that's nice to hear
I like this one it's that it's who
they'll kick the door open more menacing
missing black man isn't really this
though it really is it's like the I mean
that's such a conundrum because if she
recognizes I know they're fine it's just
the ones I've been brainwashed to
believe exist well but it's it's clap
like this is classism right here said
she's she's literally saying I don't
want the the lower classes to come here
but you white black yellow it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
that's a Democrats that can't afford to
live here right the people that can live
here are professional people like the
Meyers who you are no different than
except for [ __ ] skin color right so
cops cops start moving people but they
move them and then they leave and then
the people go back and then the cops are
come back and then they move them again
and so this just went on and on and
finally the cops just gave up okay
moving people and they got in their cars
and they drove off good good stuff well
that's a job done
so how left court who was nicknamed mr.
Levittown hello I'm mr. Levitin it was
considered the voice of the community
and a member of the Bristol Township
Board of Commissioners he was leading a
meeting a mile away at this time sure at
10:00 p.m. a mob of angry Levittown
Levittown errs burst in and started
yelling do something like I get like the
racism is there but there's also this
level of just [ __ ] like childlike
panic of when a kid looks at their dad
it's like yeah like it's just [ __ ]
well you know what's amazing too is them
we've like that that's sort of
volcanic reaction like where people just
explode and want change immediately has
also sort of died in us even though this
one's yeah miss like misfired like that
is something that now we just use our
phones to get we get outraged at the
device be like yeah used to bang on
doors with torches yeah
and now if you look at like today what
is it gonna take for us now to go well
that went by the time that comes it can
make oh this is ending will be
underwater like the food of Troy so
these people are mad that the police
kept making them leave the Myers lon and
one guy yelled quote my wife is foreign
born and she says the police there my
wife was foreign born and she says the
police here are worse than in Nazi
Germany hello ok everybody so basically
there's like a Jerry Springer vibe out
on that we're just the guys at the
meeting this time came to the town right
so he's saying that the Commission
should ban blacks from Levittown so
that's what they're all demanding the
demanding the Commission banned blacks
from Levittown and saying that because
they won't ban blacks they're like Nazis
right Wow so it's already that's a reach
that major spy it's just a couple years
after the war and they've already lost
the understanding about Nazi yeah pretty
fast too the commissioners tried to
explain to the group that because of the
law and what the courts had ruled they
had no legal standing to ban black
people the mob was not having it no
quote there's no law in this land that
says we had to live alongside them
alongside them that family moved in
caused the riot not us actually the riot
started a couple of couple things real
quick yeah uh-huh
you started the right no no they did
they moved in nope how am I supposed to
react to people moving in who are black
like it's the law no okay you have okay
I don't think we can no okay all right
does anyone else want to say no okay
look there's there's a line of people
behind you
also have things to say sir taking a
shocking turn someone put a little put a
bang key on him and hold it hold hey
that's the law
okay little cutie Shh
why don't you do me a favor we're gonna
do okay we're gonna take you to your
house we're gonna put you on the couch
okay we get some apple slices so warm
milk maybe a little chocolate but not a
lot mm-hmm
and then you're gonna take a little nap
and see you feeling when you wake up so
yeah we won't we need from you as big
boy strength okay need you to be a big
boy okay okay let's stop putting race on
it okay just kind of over trying to get
away from all right all right come on
guys put him in my arms let me rock him
so the mobs not having it mr. Levittown
told them it was time for them all to go
home is that how mobs work all right mom
I think you're about done all right
gentlemen all right mob I've heard
enough but then a second group poured in
right at that moment now there were
about a hundred shouting people I win
the second mob
hey we're mob - hey what a night mob so
basically was having us the cops are
clearing the street and when they did a
bunch of people go we gotta go to the
meeting and then it was a woman yelled
quote you should tell that black
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] to get the
hell out of here now she's talking about
Daisy okay mister Levittown had had it
he started yelling at them he yelled at
her quote you punk
get out here every one of you get out of
here then mister Levittown started
crying as he yelled because the precious
place he lived in was crumbling in front
of his eyes quote crying and yelling she
lives in America she has a right to live
wherever she wishes Wow what's going on
there well the [ __ ] the guys who are
normal or like what the [ __ ] is
happening might but that's mr. Levittown
breaking down yeah because what he sees
is like oh my god all these people I
live with are [ __ ] mom
okay God so he's having a different
breakdown sure which we recently
experienced as a nation
so mr. meeting ended mr. Levitin went
home and when he got there one of the
leaders of the pack called and said the
cops wouldn't let them meet and mr.
Levittown screamed in the phone put a
goddamn flag on your house and go meet
so okay
wait who's he saying that - so he's
saying put a flag on your house again
you wanna have a [ __ ] meeting put a
flag on your house and have a meeting
okay
the next day I guess you need a flag to
have an official I mean I think this is
one of those digs that gets lost in the
time but it was good yeah no I'm sure at
the time he was like oh how dare you you
said to put a flag on our house and have
one can you believe that so nerve this
is what's happening outside the meeting
oh my god so now oh this might be the
next day wait I mean let me go back I
don't put that up yet yeah yeah that's
the next day I apologize the next day
this is big news newspaper and magazine
reporters from Philadelphia New York and
other US cities descended on Levittown
TV and radio crews were all over the
place the Levittown Chief of Police
wired the governor quote the citizens of
Levittown are out of control he asked
for the State Police to come the
governor made a statement condemning the
mobs some people came to support the
Myers but they were far dwarfed by the
haters about a mile from the Myers home
six hundred protesters gathered the next
night outside a fetter n' of voron a
veteran of Foreign Wars Post so that was
the picture I just put up this is this
is outside a meeting of a little while
but a mile away from where black people
have moved if you're the Myers are you
like you probably can't even answer this
but I wonder how much is actual like
logistical predicament as far as you've
just moved and bought a place or
whatever what you can do and how and how
much is like [ __ ] these people
logistical EU you know the only people
they were going to his dad's house at
night you can't move into your parents
house when you've got a family and
you've put all your money into this
[ __ ] logistically you're [ __ ] yeah
okay
so so the this that the VA the VFW this
big [ __ ] meeting is happening it had
been rented for a dollar what cuz one of
the lead racists was a member and so he
rents it and they're like yeah yeah
we'll help you out with that great cause
leaders took to the stage and gave
speeches denouncing the Myers some
priests had come to try and talk some
sense into the crowd but it didn't go
well
we just want to talk about hanging up
laundry on Sundays you guys are still
doing it one man tried to fight one of
the priests I'll show him after that the
man said he was the chairman of the
quote Levittown betterment committee he
just came up with that they were they've
just foreign I beat up a priest I'm in
charge of the betterment part now you
know if you beat up a priest then you're
part of the making things good it's very
simple it says it's simple like catching
a leprechaun and getting a wish if you
beat up a priest you become in charge of
betterment the purpose of the committee
was to find quote legal ways of force to
get the meijer to move out they pick
volunteers to go door-to-door and
Levittown to talk to people to help
drive the Meyers out all right who wants
the canvas people yelled out different
they were they were [ __ ] cameras now
yeah it's gotta be really comfortable to
have a an election people yelled out
different ideas of ways to get them out
one man yelled quote burn them out okay
we're not let's not do those right away
Gus I'm sure there were cheers when they
said ya know it feels like Springer at
the end of the meeting the Leviton
betterment committee now a thousand
strong March to the Myers home the Myers
weren't even there they had gone to
Bill's parents house in York but when
the mob got to deep-green Lane they
found 21 straight trooper troopers with
clubs guarding the house this did not
stop them using Union techniques see if
I can find this picture that's better
than a fence so they using union
techniques oh yeah here's so they start
they start protests marching so they're
in there in
groups of two and they're marching like
they're in a picket line okay and
they're marching in pairs there's
teenagers parents mothers babies and
strollers they're clapping their hands
and rhythm they went around the block so
now they've formed this big just right
picket line of people around the block
right you saw the blocks yeah I've been
huge blocks so someone couldn't handle
the simple protest method and threw a
rock at the side of the house elsewhere
a classic racists were really coming out
of the woodwork at the nearby Levittown
Walt Disney elementary school an
eight-foot bamboo cross wrapped in
turpentine soaked rags was set on fire
oh well that's a lot you just jammed a
lot into one sentence that's a Disney
what the dismal Disney elementary school
okay so this means the Klan is here oh
boy because no one else is gonna burn
across it's the [ __ ] clan the clans
arrived right another man threw a rock
through one of the Meyers windows in
front of a reporter
then said to the reporter quote he's
probably a nice guy but every time I
look at him I see a mm drop off and the
value of my house so this is just a
business change is your business thing
I'm doing here and when I'm throwing a
rock it's not like I hate this guy madam
it's just like you know I got a it's
it's to make money it's a small sect of
racists called business racists making
money I'm making money the nights and
days just go on like this crowds are
gathering they're throwing rocks they're
protesting against this black family
rumors are swirling why I heard they're
not even black one guy that sign he was
like there he goes the rumors are so
crazy there's no reason to even tell him
like if you told if I told you this you
would say that's insane he goes but then
everyone's believing it what are they
people thought the Myers had been sent
and their house was paid for by black
agitators okay
another was that the Myers just moved
from white neighborhood to white
neighborhood all across the country
doing the same thing that sounds super
plot that sounds like that about the
ones I've heard so far that one sounds
likely I mean that's that's exactly what
I don't think a pregnant woman would do
yeah no just definitely yeah for sure
just well she's probably been pregnant
Dave oh my god I've got a pillow under
there
Aaron's yawning they're going to Aaron's
yawning Oh yelling
yawning okay yawning boys was great yes
is what we're doing now the cross burned
across is burn in the Wechsler yard
right people originally sold the house
for the Myers oh oh okay there's another
new house okay right yep okay you know
the cross was burned outside a friendly
Quakers home who had spoken out about
the Meyers right to live where they
wanted okay so now anybody who comes out
and says you're getting leave them alone
this is this is how America should be
they're getting targeted right
bullets were embedded in that cross and
when it was burned they went off just
kind of a kind of a cool feature just to
sort of change the metallic iing of the
KKK I mean look I'm not I'm not for
cross burning but but upgrades are cool
I'm thinking this one yeah you've got
like the Banksy of the KKK crosses this
one's gonna be really great
the Levittown betterment committee who
was now being called by I think if
somebody had he smarts to start pulling
bullets in them they'd start figuring
out better tactics than just like let's
burn it again well some guys are just
super into cross burning and it's like
tradition and yeah it is tradition it's
about it's actually about their
ancestors more than it is about it's an
homage man yeah so Leviton betterment
committee which now people who support
the Meyers are calling it the bitter
mint committee Oh keep [ __ ] killing it
they're knocking on doors with a
petition
quote protesting the mixing of Negroes
in our previously all-white community
and asking people to sign it so you
can't have language in a contract that
says whites only but you can have a
betterment Commission going door to door
asking to sign a petition to get black
people out yeah okay that's freedom of
speech shank yeah a lot of people signed
it a lot of people did not those who
disagreed created this Citizens
Committee for Levittown they okay so
that's like super bad there's battling
battling committees okay
the circulator petition that condemned
the violence and appealed for calm we
want you to sign a petition that says
that you don't like the other petition
and then this petition that says no more
petitioning white Levittown was breaking
down along Civil War lines all because
of black family have moved in a group
moved into an empty house right behind
the Meijer they unfurled a giant
Confederate flag and loudly played the
song Old Man River all day and all night
hoping to drive the Meijer away they
ended up driving themselves away yeah
they weren't that bothered by it
Daisie quote I thought it was kind of
funny somebody asked if we could stand
the noise and I said if the neighbors
can stand it we can too yeah at this
point they're just like right now I feel
like they've been through the worst of
it and so now they're seeing just stupid
[ __ ] right and they know right like
it feels like maybe and you know you
can't separate the shoes but it feels
like maybe they're like well if we
haven't been shot at or actually attack
now it's probably not gonna happen yeah
well when the tactic becomes they're
gonna play music yeah I think you're
sort of like they're crying it out by
now newspapers from all over the world
are carrying the Meyers story it's in
the New York Times The Washington Post
the London Times the Manchester Guardian
and Pravda most of them attacked
Levittown's racial bigotry and the PR
was bad but not locally the four major
newspapers that served with Levittown
area were silent on the subject an
editorial in the Philadelphia Daily News
condemned the violence but said quote
civil rights are not involved here what
what the [ __ ] is it oh yeah what do you
blaming it on what what I mean at least
there's a recognition of reality but
they're not about civil rights it's just
black people we condemn it but it's not
racist goodbye nothing to do with that a
philadelphia evening bulletin editorial
said it was okay to protest a Negro
moving into their community the
Philadelphia Inquirer and Leviton Times
did no took no editorial stance what's
the way the Levittown times didn't have
any no stand no took no Levittown times
did it have anything on it no position
what the [ __ ] is on the front page of
the Levantine baseball scores what's
going on with the town fan says pro and
con on the seventh night over 500
gathered
but the state troopers decided to end it
this time they pushed the crowd back a
block from the Myers home and made sure
they stayed back so for the first time
ever now they've pushed them away from
the house okay
the crowd responded by throwing bricks
and rocks at the troopers right so
they're they're pushing them back that's
when troopers were chinstraps just the
way I like to know right they get you
Shep I got their [ __ ] sticks out
which means they can [ __ ] well look
at that kid why would you bring your
[ __ ] kid to your white race rally
like well when you put it like that Dave
I mean Jesus Christ leave the kids at
home for your [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
want him growing up open-minded so
people start throwing rocks to the
troopers the cops are seriously not down
with that because they're cops and they
charged and they just are beating the
[ __ ] out of the crowd with their batons
men were hit on the head and I read this
in a newspaper women were hit on their
box
what Wow weird compromise they've found
the loophole is the bottom so many in
the crowd became hysterical now that
totally makes sense because these are
suburban like these are these are
suburban people who are not used to what
it's really [ __ ] like out there on
the streets yeah yeah if you actually
want to protest and get real about some
yeah no they moved into a Levittown so
so now they're in a total [ __ ] panic
suddenly being racist in Levittown was
dangerous one police officer was hit on
the head by a rock and laid out Oh like
knocked out yeah so that image goes all
around the world okay so obviously other
cops really not down with that he has a
concussion he's taking the hospital the
officer lying flat on the lawn was
caught by news cameras arrests were made
some people in the crowd shouted gestapo
at the police again not understand the
level of irony sure absolutely
yeah after the melee so that fights over
the cops would beat everybody up some of
the larger crowd hung around and tell
the early morning hours okay at one
point they stood together and saying
America also known as my country tis of
thee like for the morning this is a
bunch of [ __ ] dumbass racists singing
my country
but after that night one more time
after that night the mob activity was
over the police made it known after one
of theirs was injured there would be no
more crowds forming and they would
handle it with violence right so you
know once you injure a cop yeah then
it's real once it's in your back yard
it's a totally different game the State
Police stayed around for a month and
protected them protected the Myers home
an injunction was obtained against the
benefit committee forbidding harassment
there's slow crawl to death the
betterment committee so there for
bidding you know the protests against
the family so I'm not sure what we're
doing anymore at the betterment
committee game seems like we just drink
coffee and eat pie once a week at this
point
catch up well that's better yeah the
Wechsler house was painted with big red
KKK letters well then you just paint it
all red
do you have that one
so they pin it and then he put it on
it's okay okay blue Wechsler got a
letter from the Ku Klux Klan telling him
to shut up or else anyone who spoke out
and said the Myers deserved to live in
Levittown were subject to threats and
abuse
two people are convicted of burning the
cross on the Wechsler schlong the press
turned against William Levitt and his
racist policies the NAACP filed charges
of discrimination against him but
William kept fighting to keep his
community segregated he clung to his
racist policies he thought the people
who wanted to let blacks live in Lebanon
were also communists the company barred
those for integration from meeting on
Leviton property it also evicted to
residents who invited black children
from a neighboring community to their
homes oh my god what yeah actually they
just invited kids over to play and they
were kicked out of their house
protests were held in Levittown's to
open up communities to minorities so
there's protests so now it's like a
thing right so now Levittown's are a
thing and there's protests happening I
don't think this is on the TV but so
there's like actual protests like so
that's a pro there's people in the
background who are against racist
policies and then the white nationalist
[ __ ] in the front well what would
the guy with the sign that says keep him
white what side is he on he is actually
that guy and the one behind that says
integration stinks
yeah what side are they on they are
actually Union guys okay they're there
for another thing yeah they're they're
just trying that's the fences white so
through it all the Myers stayed they
filed four orders of protection against
the neighbors who had gathered on their
lawn so anybody who was involved they
fired filed protection orders they had a
lawyer that was had done this around the
country and I was helping out they made
friends in the neighborhood because
there's also that's thing about watching
that documentary there's a lot of people
are like what the [ __ ] is going on like
like the the [ __ ] are a minority but
a loud one boy I wonder what that's like
one day the group leader who had given
speeches on their lawn came to their
front door okay he was running for
office and asked for their vote what
what what every vote counts I know that
I know that we've had our differences
and I'm actually running for office to
get you kicked out but I could really
use your vote it'd be nice and
neighborly of you to vote for me they
did not vote for him why a second black
family the Mosby's moved in in 1958 the
reaction was much more subdued but they
dealt with quite a bit of racism their
daughter said she was beaten up at
school every day the mother of the
family didn't believe in taking much
[ __ ] soon after they moved in a car
pulled up and men started yelling
obscenities so Julia Mosby grabbed a
baseball bat ran outside and starting
beating the [ __ ] out of their cars and
drove statement early I mean I wish that
was on film because that's like the
greatest ball
the Myers move back to York in 1961 so
less than four years okay I bet you a
hundred bucks is because of the kids
right William Levitt eventually sold his
stake in his company he sold it for what
would be six hundred and eighty million
dollars today Wow he looks like he
finally formed into what I thought he
should look like early doesn't he look
like he just like Trading Places
yeah exactly yeah yeah the communities
became less segregated after he sold
them less segregated less segregated the
jet watching the documentary the general
feeling in low town was that they
weren't against minorities moving in
while 60,000 people lived there only a
thousand or so went out on the streets
to protest Wow so I mean numbers would
have been nice for 2000 to show up and
say it's okay Wow Hofstra University
professor Herbert Rosenbaum who lived
there said quote in those years even
liberal people like ourselves tended to
take residential segregation for granted
without approving it none of us went out
into the street to change it so
admittedly saying we could have done
something but then you know but then
you're literally like it is that it is
at that point the job of cops because if
you go out on the street and you're
fight then you're fighting in the
streets you're literally fighting your
neighbors in the streets well day
morning lead I mean it's that I think
that's what would you call 2019 yeah I
mean I would I would I was I'm a huge
proponent of taking out the leaders
Wayne Levitt had changed America he
created a country full of suburban
knights and white flight the effect he
had will always be felt great American
Bill O'Reilly was raised in a Levittown
community called South Westbury
obviously it had no effect on him yeah
it's good that he came out of that
William Levitt died in 1994 saddled with
great debt from continually trying to
repeat the success of Levittown and
failing in 1987 William Meyers died at
his home at age 65 and Daisy died in
2011 at age 86 on the campaign trail
Donald Trump would talk about the six
sass I'm Levittown Oh God really
it's called the dog whistle oh god I
didn't even know the dogs I didn't even
know that was whistling yeah yeah dogs
whistle I guess that's why it's a dog
whistle huh dogs have whistles because
some of us other animals can't hear it
yeah you know the usual disappointed
angry
the first family moving in to live it
down right there yeah it's uh you know
when you there's a there's there's just
so much like always there's a lot of
race race [ __ ] going on right now but
when you when you when you get down to
the oh the systemic nature of it and how
access was denied so that's that's not
just like that's not just exclusion and
and white people that's all those people
bought houses for cheap yeah and then
built up equity and money and became
wealthier because of it right and black
fans were excluded from that right and
so when people say like what didn't they
freaking well they weren't allowed to
yeah yeah that's why yeah like all that
became money that people then sold and
bought a new house like that's that's
that's supposedly the American dream
just you're just excluding people from
it well I think that's a part of the
American dream I think that's insinuated
a little yeah
I think I think that today if we had our
Supreme Court oh they were ruled against
it absolutely would have a different
story right now absolutely and who knows
what that would have done you know
absolutely I think I was thinking that
the whole time that really is that and
it that happened a lot you know where it
would come down to the Supreme Court
speakers made some of the most horrific
and dehumanizing decisions in the
history of mankind
they have been at times of [ __ ]
abomination yeah and I'm sorry but
citizens united is completely unraveled
America and they've destroyed it now you
think now I I think when you think of
the court now it's like they're I mean
man they're [ __ ] some monster it's
not
yeah I mean like I I need to go to Ruth
cater Ruth Ruth Ginsburg Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's house daily and like hydrate
well you wouldn't want to talk to you
about Colin Kaepernick though would you
no that's the problem right it's like
you're like truly that's that that's
what it's always so amazing is like you
know the way that it's an argument down
to Republicans or Democrats and you're
just like hey I mean when you've lived
in it enough you're just like they just
that we need more goddamn choices we
can't just you know we don't need
anything you know we don't need old
people yeah you know you need to get to
a certain age and get the [ __ ] out
because you know why not because you're
too old because you don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening anymore and we said we
sent someone a couple years ago when
there was a patent troll coming after a
podcast and we raised like $60,000 you
went through the ffs we sent a we sent
lawyers up there and I when it happened
I talked to one of the women because I
was one of the guys leading in and she
said Dave I can't talk to them about
podcasts because I go up to the hill and
80% of them don't know what email is
because they're so rich and they're so
distance from what normal people do that
they don't use email they're told stuff
by people yeah so you're talking about
podcasts I'm literally saying they're
too old and rich to know what the [ __ ]
is happening in the world yeah that's
who represents us so these [ __ ] rich
there's no reason in the world a Supreme
Court justice would do that for life no
[ __ ] reason the world yeah so stupid
yeah and then it's the same thing with
not like Dianne Feinstein she's gonna be
[ __ ] 89 or some [ __ ] if she wins oh
[ __ ] that well also like how do you how
do you govern one like you don't need to
worry about twenty years from now right
like how are you in the headspace of
like I mean truly that's just like
that's not you know that's like worried
like who worries about the next hotel
guests yeah you know nobody gives a [ __ ]
well it's been quite rule right out of
that yeah that'll change alright anyway
that's white flight that's how it
started and it worked out great party
now sat inside yeah yeah well yeah I'm
not gonna keep going but yeah of course
and and I'm worth like yeah genuinely
like you think about the future and it's
like well it's just what country you
should live in yeah got a lot of choices
I think I might move to one of those
[ __ ] holes
yeah baby that was fun we like to laugh